[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to if you've been keeping up to
date with my videos then you'll know
that earlier in the week I dropped some
tidbits on leaks that we've had it in
regards to the final episode of Game of
Thrones and whilst it covered some minor
parts and revelations that was still a
lot missing well an entire episode
breakdown has just leaked online and not
only does it cement the prior things we
found out but it also adds a lot more
detail throughout this video I'll be
breaking down the plot of episode 6 in
all of its entirety from beginning to
end
whilst this is a leak it is consistent
with what we've already seen but do take
it with a pinch of salt
it's obviously we can't verify this
until we see the episode for ourselves
from here on out its full spoilers ahead
so if you don't want to know anything
about the final episode in the season
then this is your last last chance to
turn off the video without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video I hope you enjoy it
now sit back relax and let's get into my
full episode breakdown of the Game of
Thrones season 8 finale
okay so I'll pretty much be reading most
of this verbatim and adding in my own
thoughts and comments to hopefully help
with the narrative as we go along anyway
this episode opens with Jon Davos and
Tyrion walking through the aftermath of
King's Landing Tyrion walks through
what's left of the castle and sees
Jamie's hand so we start to uncover the
rubble and he confirms both Cersei and
Jaime are dead over the last week we've
had reports that Jaime could still be
alive due to him not receiving an
after-show send-off
but this leak confirms that the
character is indeed dead and up there
with Varys the red woman and the rest of
the characters that D&D couldn't be
bothered to write a proper M for anyway
they find grey worm and his men and they
have Lannister soldiers trapped and
they're about to kill them Jon tries to
tell grey worm to stop - which grey worm
tells John that it's the Queen's orders
then they cut to Dany giving a speech
pretty much saying how she's freed the
people from King's Landing and the new
goal is freeing the rest of the
Danny turns to terian and tells him he
committed treason and terian tells her
that she's killed thousands of innocent
people and he takes off the hands pin
and throws it at the ground due to this
betrayal at Danny sends him to prison
this is consistent with the way the show
seemed to be going for the character and
tyrion has pretty much had a hard time
dealing with the way that Danny has
changed so rapidly over the past season
which yeah he's not the only one there
any way from here John goes to see Danny
at which punch he's sitting on the Iron
Throne alone John tells her that she
needs to stop being crazy and that grey
worm killed the Lannister army from the
previous scene Danny tells John that
she's doing it for the people John
pretends to understand and the greens
but he's tricking her when a guard is
down he stabs and he kills her
which if this is the way she goes out is
pretty disappointing
drogon comes and he's standing over her
body and he melts the Iron Throne and
carries her away I can see this being
pretty disappointing if the happens
especially the Iron Throne bit as who
finally sits there has been teased for
so long that there's no way that this
doesn't let people down anyway grey worm
has Tyrion and John as his prisoners
after their betrayal the council led by
Sansa tells grey worm to release John
back to them but he refuses that's when
Tyrion says that the new king or queen
should decide what happens to John Sam
suggests a democratic vote for the new
king which Tyrion calls stupid
however they go ahead with this and the
council votes and decides that bran
should be the king bran then picks
Tyrion as his hand this is consistent
with the leaks that we've had so far and
though many myself included switched and
said they changed to Sansa this is a
point of contention which I'll discuss
later in this episode Torian tells John
that his punishment is going back to the
wall and to join the Nights Watch grey
worm accepts Jon's punishment but he
doesn't bend the knee and then he leaves
with his troops and Dothraki Army and
together they go on ships to free the
slave cities they show Terry in leading
the council and John says goodbye to
Sansa and Arya Arya tells them that she
isn't going back home and that she's
going to explore whatever's west of
Westeros because that's where no one has
been the final scene is a closing
montage
you see area on a ship with Sansa ruling
Winterfell this is sort of where the
confusion between brown and Sansa has
come from for many I think because with
the leaks before this being so sparse
there was a lot of back and forth on it
so just to clarify a bran is the king of
the Seven Kingdoms and Sansa is the
ruler of Winterfell Jon doesn't stay at
the wall and he reunites with Tommen and
ghost Bhumi pets the other fates are as
follows the council members are Samwell
Tarly the Grandmaster Davos Seaworth
master of ships bran master of coin and
Highgarden Brienne Lord Commander of the
Kingsguard Yara Greyjoy lord of I and
Islands Robin Lord of Kingdom of the
mountain and the Vale Gendry a lot of
storms end and yon rice Lord of
Runestone Sam mentions that they seem
drogon in some location but unsure and
brandy says I'll look for him they don't
have a master of laws and whisperers and
Tyrion is looking for the right people
to fill these spots and no they don't
clarify what Brian was doing during the
Battle of Winterfell and that's pretty
much everything you have on the episode
but this is how it goes down I can
definitely see a lot of people being
disappointed on the whole as I think the
majority of characters get a full deal I
know it's Game of Thrones and you should
never expect a happy ending but this
feels like quite poor handling and I'm
still kind of helping in the back of my
mind that this isn't how it goes down
but more and more every day as these
leaks come out they seem to back up the
ones before obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the leaks and if you
think they will happen or not comment
below and let me know and if you enjoy
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my 11 minute video of
Game of Thrones actors being
disappointed about how season 8 has
turned out which will be linked at the
end this is the channel for people who
are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe your definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll
next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]